let's go to the six six one area code
who's calling from six six one today hi
my name is Justin Brown hey Justin
what's going on oh nothing man I mean I
was wondering just another day in
paradise here in Bakersfield it's funny
and stuff well I was wondering if you've
ever seen the movie idiocracy is that
the Bill Maher one no that's Religulous
right wait which one's idiotic read it
that's religiously out of Bill Maher one
Aquos he was by Mike judge the creator
of things like king of the hill and
beavis and butt-head you know I don't
remember if I've seen it or just read
about it I don't remember offhand I
highly recommend watching just you know
it's put on Netflix or Hulu or whatnot
um anyways I think we're closely
approaching it it's a comedy satire but
I didn't argue for I didn't see it I
didn't see it but I know I know what
you're referring to
highly recommended I think it's a
Saturday Night Live production or you
know
my question though is how to deal with
opposition people when you're debating
them or having a discussion and they
result to ad hominem attacks or straw
man
well it depends if you are are you
trying to change their mind are you
trying to score points or are you trying
to de-escalate when they switch to add
homonyms what are you trying to do well
a lot of times I have to resolve the
de-escalation and point out you know
some of the flaws and their arguments or
I just ask them to supply evidence what
yeah it seems to be a foreign concept
for a lot of people well listen I mean
there's there's no I I sort of sort of
careful about even giving this advice
but there's nothing that will fire up
someone who disagrees with you and is
starting to use ad hominem x' and
escalate more than saying why are you
becoming so emotional about this and I
say that I mean you can actually say
that and then they will probably say
something like because you're not making
any sense or you're wrong or whatever
and it might open up the door for you to
say okay can you in a calm way
to me what I've said that's incorrect
and really try to like narrow the
conversation to specific assertions
because of what happens a lot of times
especially when it's just kind of casual
political debate is there's kind of a de
facto Gish gallop Gish gallop is when
somebody just says a whole bunch of
stuff and the idea in a debate is the
other person just like can't keep up
with all the different arguments and
refute them one by one so what can be
very useful is to try to slow the entire
thing down it's your judgment whether
you want to tell the other person to
calm down people really don't like being
told to calm down
and then try to focus in on one thing at
a time and say okay hold on you said
you're in favor of Trump's tax cuts
because tax cuts for the rich are good
for the economy can you tell me of
another tax cut in history that was good
for the economy and how did you know
that it was good right try to sort of
like compartmentalize into specific
questions that will often either end the
conversation get the person even more
upset or maybe get you somewhere
productive mmm fair enough okay yeah I
could serve myself a progressive so most
of the time I am arguing with people who
are conservative right and so but
pointing out a historical example would
really help out I really think that can
be useful is especially once you
understand that a lot of us we think
that we have come to our political
positions on the basis of rational
thought and what people like Jonathan
Hite and others have sort of discovered
through through moral psychology
research is that very often we have an
initial intuition and then later we find
rationalizations so later when someone
asks us why do you believe that we cite
only the rationalization so like an
example would be abortion
most of us immediately have like an
intuitive reaction where we say we are
okay with it or not okay with it if
you're not okay with it you then go and
find ways to rationalize that position
but you still sort those out because of
that intuitive gut response if you
understand that you can sometimes also
have better conversations with people
right on I really be sure there okay
appreciate the call thank you so much
have a good day right take care